et enfin maintenant aux etats unis c'est
traditionnellement le premier état qui
votent lors des primaires avant la
présidentielle l'iowa donald trump y
tient on y tient un grand meeting ce
samedi plusieurs milliers de personnes
sont attendues la correspondance à
washington de dôme abonnés
il s'agit ce samedi du premier meeting
de donald trump dans l'état de l'iowa
depuis la campagne présidentielle de
2020 il devrait être entouré de figure
locale du parti républicain et c'est une
étape finalement assez révélatrice des
réelles ambitions de l'ancien président
pour la prochaine élection
présidentielle de 2024 parce que
traditionnellement l'état de l'iowa est
un état stratégique c'est dans cet état
que son lancer les processus de
désignation des candidats pour les
élections aux états unis en tout cas
depuis plusieurs décennies il ya donc
aussi une portée symbolique pour ce
déplacement de l'ancien locataire de la
maison blanche qui va pouvoir tester sa
base électorale dans cet état rural il
arrive plutôt en terrain conquis puisque
selon les sondages il est plus populaire
aujourd'hui qu'il ne l'était lorsqu'il
était président des états unis selon ces
mêmes sondages plus d'un habitant de
l'iowa sur deux a une opinion favorable
de donald trump mais pour autant et bien
à la candidature de donald trump pour la
prochaine présidentielle ne fait pas
l'unanimité au sein du parti républicain
certains estiment que la personnalité de
l'ancien président est trop clivante
certains veulent d'abord se focaliser
sur les élections de mi-mandat qui vont
avoir lieu l'année prochaine aux etats
unis et puis il y a aussi des
concurrents qui commence à s'avancer on
parle de plus en plus de mike pence qui
est l'ancien vice-président de donald
trump et qui ironie de l'histoire sera à
lui aussi dans l'iowa ce sera au début
du mois de novembre en tout cas ce
déplacement de l'ancien président dans
l'iowa intervient au moment où la
commission d' enquête du congrès en
charges des événements du 6 janvier au
capitole a assigné deux nouveaux témoins
pour des auditions il s'agit de
personnes qui faisaient partie de
l'entourage très proche de donald trump
au moment des événements qui se sont
déroulés au capitole et il ya plusieurs
médias qui ont relayé ces derniers jours
une lettre qui aurait été écrite par un
des avocats de le trump et qui invite à
ces personnes à ne pas se rendre à ces
auditions en invoquant le fait qu'il
existe dans le droit américain un
privilège pour les présidents un
privilège qui rend confidentiel leur
communication et leur échange mais on a
appris ce vendredi que l'administration
de la maison blanche l'administration de
joe biden a donné son autorisation aux
archives nationales pour qu'elle
transmette un certain nombre de
documents à cette commission denquête
des documents otamment notamment autour
des activités de donald trump pour cette
journée du 6 janvier dernier lorsqu'il
ya eu ces événements au capitole
évidemment ce sujet devrait donc être
abordé par donald trump lors de son
meeting on sait que depuis des semaines
les démocrates font tout pour tenter de
prouver que l'ancien président a une
responsabilité dans les violences qui
ont été commises le 6 janvier lui a
toujours réfuté ces accusations et
continue d'affirmer près d'un an
maintenant après l élection de 2020
qu'il est selon lui le réel vainqueur de
cette élection